عِنْدَ التَّلَةِ تَسْكُنْ عَنْزَةْ  *** فِي بَيْتٍ عَالٍ ومَنِيعْ
تَرْعَى هِيَ سِتَّةَ حِمْلاَنْ ***   ولَدَيْهَا بِالمَهْدِ رَضِيعْ
فِي كُلِّ صَبَاحٍ لاَ تَخْرُجْ ***  حَتَّى تُنَبِّهَهُمْ وتُحَرِّجْ
صَوْتِي يَا اَوْلاَدُ رَفِيعْ * ** والذِّئْبُ لَهُ صَوْتٌ مُزْعِجْ
سَأُرَدِّد لَو آَتِي لحْنَا * ** لاَ يَعْرِفُهُ إِلاَّ نَحْنْ
حِمْلاَنِي يَا حِمْلاَنِي  *** يَا نَغَمَاتِ الأَلْحَانِ
إِفْتَحُوا يا أبنائي البَابْ ***  هَيَّا تَعَالُوا لأَحْضَانِي
جِئْتُ بِلَبَنٍ يُشْبِعُكُمْ  *** مَعَهُ حُبِّي وحَنَانِي
اِسْتَرَقَ الذِّئْبُ السَّمْعَ *** عَرِفَ الكَلِمَاتِ فَهِمَ
ذَهَبَ إِلَيْهِمْ دَقَّ البَابَ *** غَنَّى كَالْعَنْزَةِ نَغَمَا
حِمْلاَنِي يَا حِمْلاَنِي  *** يَا نَغَمَاتِ الأَلْحَانِ
إِفْتَحُوا يا أبنائي البَابْ ***  هَيَّا تَعَالُوا لأَحْضَانِي
جِئْتُ بِلَبَنٍ يُشْبِعُكُمْ  *** مَعَهُ حُبِّي وحَنَانِي
اِذهبْ اِذهَبْ يَا كَذابْ *** نَعْرِفُ أنَكَ اَنْتَ الذِئِّبْ
صَوْتُكَ خَشِنٌ وَمُنَفِّرْ *** وَلَدَى مَامَا صَوْتٌ عَذْبْ
اِذهبْ الذِّئْبُ إِلَى العَطَّارْ  *** وأَتَى بِدَوَاءٍ فَعَّالْ
وبِصَوْتٍ كَالمَاعِزِ صَارْ  *** غَنَّى لِيُدْخِلَهُ الأَطْفَالْ
حِمْلاَنِي يَا حِمْلاَنِي  *** يَا نَغَمَاتِ الأَلْحَانِ
إِفْتَحُوا يا أبنائي البَابْ ***  هَيَّا تَعَالُوا لأَحْضَانِي
جِئْتُ بِلَبَنٍ يُشْبِعُكُمْ  *** مَعَهُ حُبِّي وحَنَانِي
خَدَعَ الحِمْلاَنَ الشِّرِّيرْ *** فَتَحُوا البَابَ بِلاَ تَفْكِيرْ
اِبْتَلَعَ جَمِيعَ السِّتَّةْ  *** لَكِنْ بَقِيَ هُنَاكَ صَغِيرْ
عَادَتْ أُمُّهُمُ فَزِعَتْ * ** مِنْ أَصْغَرِهِمْ قَدْ عَلِمثْ
ذَهَبَتْ لِلْذِّئْبِ ونَطَحَتْهُ ***  وجَمِيعُ المَاعِزِ خَرَجَتْ